Our mistakes are nothing new or startling.
[inaudible]
think about that. Most of the time,
most of the time, think about this. Most
of the time when you make a mistake,
it's something that you already knew.
You actually know you're making
the mistake when you're making it.
Okay?
Here's another thing he says,
errors spell the difference between
professionalism and mediocrity.
It's the little things. It's the
little mistakes that you make.
Next thing he thinks says discipline
soldiers are the main ingredient in
victory. Well, guess what?
The main ingredient in victory
in your life is discipline. Yeah.
All Day. All Day.
He says there's no magic formula or
sweat list's solution by which one can
achieve their goals. I think
he just said, there is no,
there is no shortcut. There is no hack.
There's no sweat list solution. You,
you're gone. I have to work.
Then he says this, no military unit is
ever completely trained. Guess what?
Neither are you. Neither am I.
There is always weakness to
work on. Always a lot of them.
Hmm.
He says this in Vietnam, primer combat
is too serious of business to permit.
Easy excuse of even one mistake.
Okay?
Now think about this. Okay? Comments,
too serious of business. Why is that?
It's cause you can die. But guess
what? We're all going to die.
We're all going to die. So why would we,
why would we allow ourselves
to make easy, easy excuses?
Why would you allow that?
Hmm? Combat is life and death.
So is life
so you shouldn't allow yourself these
easy excuses. And in the last section
that he, that he talks about that I
read, it can absolutely be applied.
It can absolutely, absolutely be
applied. He says another weakness,
common among junior leaders
is the inaccurate reporting
of the estimate of the
situation.
They are either so exaggerated or
Wolff so watered down that they are not
meaningful.
[inaudible].
Now again, if you apply this
to yourself, what you realize
[inaudible]
is that you got these junior leaders that
they're lying to the chain of command.
I mean they're, they're exaggerating
or they're watering things down,
but they're basically lying
to the chain of command.
And how does that translate
to us? We lie to ourselves.
Mm.
That's how it translates
to us. Lie to ourselves.
We don't tell ourselves the way
things really are and when we do that,
then we can't fix our problems.
If we can't fix our problems,
we're not going to improve. So we
have to be truthful to ourselves.
Okay?
I have to be truthful to myself.
You have to be truthful to yourself.
You have to stop rationalizing,
stop making excuses.
Stop telling yourself little water down
the assessments of where you're really
at, telling yourself the truth
so that you can get where you want
to go. You can be who you want to be.
You can be who you should be,
who you should be. When you do
what you know you should do.
When you pay attention to the little
things, when you implement discipline,
true and unflinching and on mitigated
discipline in your life. When you stop,
when you stop trying to
find a sweat list solution,
when you look for weaknesses to work on,
when you allow no easy
excuses and all that starts,
when you stop lying to yourself,
can you stop lying to yourself?
That's when you can be calm,
who you know you should be.
When you tell yourself the truth about
where you are so you can make sure you
are in the right place, and if
you're not in the right place,
that you can get yourself
on the path to get there.
The path of discipline, the path
of hard work, and the path of
truth.